we're gonna go out to denver colorado
and have a conversation with uh haley
haley good afternoon how can dr d and i
serve
hi thank you for taking my call sure um
my husband and i ran into some income
and employment mishaps when coveted hit
and so in turn we've decided to
start paying off debts and getting in a
better better financial situation
so that when things like this happen we
aren't so stressed out
um we are just getting back on track we
made some lifestyle changes
and we ended up needing to surrender
two vehicles back in july
and we now have a deficit because we
rolled negative
into them so i'm wondering if we should
set up
a payment plan with our original
creditor
or if we should let it go to collections
and try and settle
settle for a lesser amount later on
gotcha
good question good question uh what's
your income at right now haley
um i just started a new job and my
husband's income
is fluctuating he's a truck driver in
the oil field
so on the low end his income is about 50
000 per year but could go up to 90 with
overtime
and then my salary is 58 000 per year
58 so bare minimum you all could be
making about a hundred and eight
thousand dollars a year in denver
colorado which is
not too bad out there okay so that's
where we are right now
what's your total amount of debt
um without the deficit we're probably at
about 40
with the deficit include everything
except for your home mortgage
um we only have one deficit amount so
far we haven't received the other letter
because it hasn't sold yet the other
vehicle
um so just what we have right now would
be 55 000. that's a total amount of debt
55 correct so be 40 in
well the deficit was about 15 on that
first one yeah correct
okay and what was the other car that you
uh turned in that you haven't gotten a
deficit for yet
it was a truck an f-150 and how much did
you owe on it
about 46 000 okay so they're going to
probably sell that for about 15
15 to 20 000 max normally what i'm
seeing with repossessions
um they get anywhere between 20 to about
maybe 35
40 max on what you owe um
and so you'll probably have another
deficit about 20k added to that so
you're gonna be in about 70k total debt
uh what i'm not going to do haley is sit
and sit here and tell you to wait
uh because i want you to attack this now
i do want to be very sensitive though
because covet has
impacted a lot of people and i want you
to hear me clearly when i say this
you're not alone
okay you're you're not alone and you can
bounce back all right uh earlier in the
show i
i told the audience i want you to speak
what you seek until you see what you
spoke
so the very first thing i'm going to
tell you has nothing to do with money
what i want you and your husband to do
is say you know what we're going to
bounce back
we're going to not just bounce back but
we're going to bounce stronger
okay so for the next two to three years
you and your husband need to get on the
dave
ramsey plan you all need to be eating
beans and rice rice and beans if you
want to add in some hot dogs in there
cut up in the rice that's cool with me
okay occasionally occasionally they add
a little bit of flavor to it i'm cool
with that seriously of course of course
because you have seventy thousand
dollars here in debt and i want that to
be gone
okay you all have to put down a plan and
you all need to stick to that plan
the cars that you lost i'mma speak this
and i believe it you're gonna get those
kind of cars back but here's what you're
gonna do
you're gonna pay cash for them in the
future so that way you do not lose them
all right so what i'm gonna do when we
hang up from here
because i want to i want to get john to
really just speak into this as well but
i want you to say on the phone and i
want
kelly uh she's going to get your
information and we're going to enroll
just on dr d and myself
we're going to get you and your husband
into ramsey plus for free
okay so that way you and your husband
can sit down
and really learn together on how do we
get not just back on our feet but how do
we lay a solid foundation
to where we do not have to come back
here ever again
and we can show our kids moving forward
how to avoid our mistakes and if
something does come up in the future
we have something solid to stand on
how does that sound haley that sounds
amazing thank you
yeah awesome we're here for you you know
and that's exactly
you know dr d why we do what we do is
um i get it you know uh covid
um this pandemic has hurt a lot of
people
um we want to help people get out of
this
but also we want to make sure no one
comes back
right to this here there are people in
situations that covets
has made them stronger right or has
tested their resolve
and stress test that rubber band and it
hasn't broke because they had an
emergency fund they haven't they weren't
buying fifty thousand dollar trucks
against fifty thousand dollar income or
whatever it happened to be right and so
this is one of your never again moments
haley good for you
good for you yeah stay on the phone
kelly's going to take
the information dr dean are going to
treat you to this please sit down with
your husband and make it happen